I have a
question how will you
contribute and be a productive American
oh I don't know how I feel about that
question Gino's family confronts Jasmine
with their concerns about her possibly
using him they are attacking me right
now this is a personal attack plus we'll
get into Jasmine's lip gloss meltdown
you're a no I'm not yes you
are that is pure reality TV gold that's
not cheating baby yeah I'm dropping you
off this is giving toddler and stressed
out Dad let's get into
it hey 90day fans fam it's melissia
before we get into Jasmine and Gino let
me give you a quick update on Sophie and
Rob last episode Sophie left Rob's house
where am I supposed to go I'm I'm in
this house I rent it by myself after
finding out he was sending inappropriate
videos to girls online this week's
episode picks up with Rob fearful that
Sophie is on a plane headed back to
London she sounds like she doesn't give
a she don't me no more like she's she
damn near done with me over this and and
the crazy part is it's like this
conversation that that Sophie's off of
me about is months old from before she
her visa got accepted and I don't even
know this girl like I literally don't
know this girl so this is this to me is
like is like free from a random person
like I don't care it seems like Rob is
trying to downplay what he did without
realizing that what he's saying is
enough for Sophie to want to break up
with him this conversation that that
Sophie's off of me about is months old
from before she her visa got accepted
where was the patience the self-control
I don't even know this girl like I
literally don't know this girl so this
is this to me is like
is like free from a random person and
you're sending videos of you pleasuring
yourself to a random girl you don't know
that's the most concerning part of it
all why do random women get to see your
package who's the porn star here aside
from all of that you're doing this while
you're in a relationship with a girl who
seems like she would have been willing
to help you get some relief no wonder he
never asked me for sexual videos he's
getting them from like I don't know how
many girls there's just no excuse as Rob
sits with the fact that the world will
now become aware of what he's done
behind closed doors Sophie calls her mom
who already can't stand Rob to tell her
what went down I checked his phone and
literally I found like the most
disgusting videos in this
phone the last message was 14 weeks ago
roughly 3 and A2
months you're welcome the last message
was 14 weeks
ago
lit can't breathe right now my heart is
going so fast oh my God I just hate the
man I hate him I just got all through
that it's been ages get into this place
where no he loves Sophie he's an actual
knob head speaking of knobhead Sophie's
Mom is rocking the Xena nuts talk about
a cool
mom what was his reaction when you told
him like what did he say so I just told
him like I know and he was like what do
you know and then I was like explain
what I saw and then and he just started
crying all this stuff they made it all
about him stupid tears forget about the
crocodile tears I'm so glad Sophie has
her mom she is the voice of reason she
needs right now and she is the comedic
relief for us you gave up your life for
the last God knows how many years to get
a visa to be with him in America and get
married cuz he won't come to you is the
ultimate disrespect you can't do the
bare minimum which is like be loyal he's
jobless he's
boring he has no sympathy now he's
talking to dirty nasty stanks online
just so that he can get his sausage to
explode it's disgusting it's disgusting
you can't be with this guy you cannot
marry him so knowing her daughter
Sophie's mom can tell she's upset and
hurt right now but she's not tired
Sophie's not ready to let go just yet
really you want to still be with him
because his conversation be mom I've
left Rob and I've got to leave I'm
coming home but we're not having that
conversation so deep down you want to
give him a chance and deep down you
still love him you can't UNL someone
that quickly I will hear his side but at
the same time I've seen the videos now
I've seen the messages I can't unsee
that Sophie's mom is pissed I can't unse
seee that and I don't know even if I was
to give him a chance cuz obviously I
have this night day thing and I'm
supposed to marry him you can't have a
relationship without trust Sophie's mom
gives her space to be an adult and make
her own
decision but she makes it clear what she
thinks is the smart thing to do if it
was me telling you what I would like you
to do just get on the plane and come to
me period a that's her baby it's like I
don't know what to do should I be strong
and leave which is going to take a lot
of strength I'm not even going to act
like that would be easy The best
scenario is we can move past this and I
can be with Rob and we can be this great
couple that we've been trying so hard to
be and then the other part of my brain
is like and then he's just going to do
it again and you're going to be hurt
again and you should have left yeah he's
cheated twice now and that's what she
knows of if they stay together more than
likely in the back of her head she's
going to always wonder if he's secretly
betraying her that's no fun why be in a
relationship that doesn't make you feel
safe then she doesn't even want kids and
he does isn't that the Telltale sign
that you're not compatible all right
let's move on let's get into Jasmine who
is anxiously getting dressed at the top
of the episode ahead of meeting Gino's
family for the first time I don't feel
in the mood I don't even know if I will
ever feel in the mood to meet them not
the best attitude to have but honest as
you can see Jasmine has her little
church dress on she's more covered up
than usual they already have this idea
that I'm a Digger and you know so I want
to look like super professional okay
girl and yeah Gino's family has not been
shy about their doubts when it comes to
Jasmine's intentions I was just wanting
to know like could this be real I mean
really do really love Gino she also
thinks they don't respect her because
she's not American your sister-in-law
texted me about the date that I can
already not pick up for the wedding
because she's having a lovely vacation
in
Florida I haven't even stepped a foot
into the United States and I'm already
receiving orders fast forward Gino and
Jasmine are headed out of the
house beautiful creature wish me love
Coco do your doggy prayers for mommy
doggy
prayers that's cute meanwhile Coco is
like a new house I'm about to go explore
once they arrive at the restaurant
Jasmine faces her first
Turtle walking in the cold windy
Michigan
rain are you cold I'm so cold right now
me you again Jasmine says the weather is
the best representation of how she's
feeling right now it's so gloomy
everything is so dark and Gino tries to
calm her down by telling her to just
just be herself don't worry just be
yourself which is usually the best
advice to give someone in a situation
like this but when it comes to
Jasmine I don't know and when I'm mad
I'm just like a volcano you know and I
say things that sometimes I don't mean
it and I have always been like that and
that's something that I really dislike
about
myself yeah Jasmine goes on to walk into
the restaurant with her head held hel
High literally as she should and she
admits that her biggest fear in this
moment is that Gino's family will talk
him into not marrying her when I first
arve the first impression that I'm
getting is that you's family seems happy
to meet me uh they're all Smiley uh very
joyful they are saying nice things
Sunny they probably don't like each
other the most it's like that sometimes
when it comes to your family member
spouse some sometimes you have to act
like you like them just to keep the
peace there going to be a lot of that
behavior on
Thanksgiving hey girl nice to see you
but in the back of my head I'm thinking
you don't deserve my cousin and we all
know that you're off the rails but I'm
going to keep it cute not say anything
you look good girl I love your dress and
keep it moving clearly I've experienced
this
feeling I'm not shocked that they're
being nice to me because the way I
picture it is like when an animal is
trying to attract their prey they're
trying to be like look friendly and all
that and they're just waiting for the
moment to attack well they have their
concerns which are reasonable but as for
now it seems like they're focused on
having a good time and getting to know
Jasmine a toast to Gino and Jasmine may
they have love in their hearts and peace
in their mind what does Uncle Marco say
chani 100 years W I love
it thank you if we continue like this
guys smart move Jasmine tap into your
humor let's play some bot ball you
ready it's a fun challenging and
exciting game there you go nice shot
that's right on
[Music]
it I am so shocked Jasmine walks on the
bot ball court and she's thrown like a
champ I mean she's killing
It Go Jasmine she's killing it they all
play bot ball for a minute but once it's
over Gino's family's concerns start to
come out we've never really met Jasmine
we've only spoken to her it's a little
bit in ways they seem a little bit
mix-matched Gino is not the best looking
guy he doesn't have the most money we're
just trying to figure out what to real
intent yeah and when we look on social
media we saw a lot of provocative type
things I guess were a little bit
concerned about why she's doing that is
she trying to get other sugar daddies so
to
speak y'all remember when Gino and
Jasmine admitted that they met on a
sugar baby website so what site did you
and Jasmine meet on so we met
on believe it or not a sugar baby site
yeah so once again their concerns make
sense fast forward Gino is with the boys
and he tells them something that turns
things
sour real quick I gave Jasmine like uh
like a quite a bit sum of money right to
buy a wedding dress and she ended up
spending the money I gave her for the
wedding dress on like a cosmetic
surgery I'm like whoa I mean I gave you
that money for the wedding dress right
so how much money are we talking about
you know like
$4,000 as a loving fan of TLC Say Yes to
the Dress compared to the women on that
show Gino gave Jasmine a pretty nice
budget for her wedding gown Gino that's
you know that's big red
flag I think she's a great person but I
think you need to get her like and I
don't mean like in line you know but she
needs to like get in line not abuse his
kindness yeah the biggest worry we have
is that she's just coming here to use
Gino thank you guys I'm so happy you
showed up today it makes me happy so
that kind of gave us more red flags to
kind of think about like she's not
grateful for the money she was given
she's going to spend it on something
else and hope that she gets more once
everyone sits down at the table Jasmine
basically tells them they're not invited
to the wedding so you guys what are you
guys thinking about for like the wedding
venue or in like when um to be honest I
I'm not quite sure about having like a
celebration for our wedding I would
rather prefer just the wedding to be
something more private you know like
maybe just gin and I and my dog Gino's
family is looking like are you serious
Jasmine says her family isn't going to
be there so she thinks it's only fair
that Gino's family isn't there either
kind of makes me feel upset cuz like she
doesn't want to celebrate with us it's
both of their weddings so I think that
Gino needs to chime in a little bit more
and if that's any indication as to
what's to come there still are some
concerns after Jasmine makes that
announcement Gino's family stops playing
nice and they get real with her so I
mean it's probably not just me but
probably a lot of people in the family
have big concerns just like how grateful
you are for everything goo's really
going to bring to
you I understand your perspective like
me coming to United States I should be
grateful for that but the way I see it
is that g should be grateful that I came
to the United States and I left
everything I have ever loved my
family my kids amazing weather you know
yeah you sacrific a lot
yeah good job Gino he knows if he didn't
back her up oh it would have been hell
to pay how will you
contribute and be a productive
American yeah he didn't hold back with
that one I'm an educated woman I speak
two languages I have worked since I am
16 years old and Jasmine Answers by
trying to prove herself I have always
worked and right now legally with this
kind of Visa I am not allowed to
work they are attacking me right now
this is a personal attack it doesn't
matter what I do I will never be good
enough for jina's family and it is
directly to the fact that I'm not
American and they already put a label on
me because of it well now that Jasmine
feels attacked that sweet Smiley side of
her is gone she's calling people out I
think it was you like suggested to you
know like AO you know I took it as an
offense when I got married to Lori I
signed one
her dad wanted me to sign a pre fre okay
so Tony
why why would you think that Gino will
need a brain off I think it would just
be like a security blanket for him I
know he's not rich but protect what he
works so hard yeah cuz he's worked so
hard his whole life and then if you had
bad intentions you come in and you take
everything he's worked his whole life
for they're trying to talk reason into
her but Jasmine's too caught up in the
emotions of it all wow go my dog is by
himself Gino's family is probably
thinking you and this dog see you guys
later see you Jasmine said see
you okay so they get in the car and what
happens next is probably one of the most
memorable reality TV moments I've ever
seen very
I it's a
goner Jack asine drops her phone and
finds lip gloss in Gino's car what is
this I have no idea what that is is that
yours who
knows this Gino's eye roll for me what
is this I don't know well you can tell
Gino is starting to get nervous he goes
from driving with one one hand to
holding on to the wheel for dear life
with two what is this I don't
know could be one of my co-workers or
some other mother my C Gino has really
been trying to match jman's energy with
these arguments lately and I cannot take
him serious wait wait wait wait wait you
go out with cowork yes I go out with
co-workers yes is that a
problem people co-workers go out
together for lunch once in a while for a
work event you were dead in a b no Dr
9466 says imagine when she finds out it
was her own lip gloss the one she
doesn't use that much so it doesn't look
familiar I wouldn't be surprised if it's
not hers though I know whoever left it
was mad that's a full bottle of lip
gloss just gone you're always looking
for no I'm not looking for anything my
cell phone just fell down and and I see
the lips and what I'm trying to get cell
phone you know how long I've had this
car hello for a long time apparently
Gino doesn't like to wash his car like
I've had that car for like 8 years Gino
you haven't cleaned your car in 8 years
I do not clean under the passenger seat
Jasmine says she knows Gino's ly because
she's learned to read his body language
and the way he's responding to me I can
tell he's scared your or
scared now I know a number of you think
that he's gaslighting her and I don't
put that past him Gino has done some
sneaky things before that have shocked
us all but in my opinion in this moment
I don't think he's nervous because he's
guilty I think he's nervous because he
knows Jasmine is about to blow this all
the way out of proportion now I'm not
saying finding lip gloss in her man's
car is not a reason reason to be upset I
think it is but we all know Jasmine's
upset is
Extreme you're you are crazy
person just want to go home you're are
so ridiculous sickening although I will
say Gino could let the tough guy act go
and soften up on her at this
moment I want to go just
sicking can't believe
it I want to
go you only found lip gloss under the
seat and you have no idea why it was
there or how it got there and you're
screaming at the top of your lungs like
there was a murder or
something
holy Anna Tyra says the extremes Jasmine
goes through are really sad like a kid
who never learned to deal with their
emotions she needs help you're a
no I'm not yes you are I never
you that's not cheating baby yeah I'm
dropping you
off this moment right here reminds me of
a toddler throwing a tantrum in their
car seat and Gino as a parent is over it
take me off yeah I'm dropping you
off I'm going back to Pama I don't want
to see you ever again okay go oh was Joo
about to call her out of her name
Jennifer says the way she cries is
hilarious
[Laughter]
ious it is she leans all the way in and
I hate to laugh because I know she's so
sad during these moments
but it's
funny to Gino's point you would think
somebody died they pull over in a
parking lot and Gino tells Jasmine he's
going to get her an Uber and a hotel
yeah anymore it's the best that's fine
yeah I didn't cheat on you or anything
you're dead din you're
dead now I don't get why she left her
phone there in the rain hopefully Gino
doesn't roll over it want to go
home to
home I don't have my passport I don't
have anything she's talking about she
doesn't have her passport is she trying
to leave immediately I'm sure her
passport is at Gino's house I don't have
my passport I don't have anything I
didn't bring any money because I don't
have money the episode ends with Jasmine
crying behind what looks to be a
shopping mall that is one dramatic
woman and I guess the fact that she
misses home is making all of this worse
next week it continues please just buy
me a ticket I want to go back the B of
yeah I didn't cheat on you or anything I
was never with any girl why you acted
like that for maybe because he knew
regardless of what he said you were
going to explode bab me home yeah I'm
dropping you
off they're going to make up they always
do all right 90day fan spam make sure
you stick with ET because we are
covering it all I will see you next
time